[Applause]
please welcome Michael Sheen Forest
Whitaker Oprah Winfrey Stanley Tucci and
Peter Sarsgaard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
his moment in the blindside when Sandra
Bullock playing a tough woman who gives
no excuse for her behavior and who tries
not to show emotions it's told by a
young man that she's taken in this is
the first time that he has laid down on
a bed and everything you need to know
about how that character feels is in her
eyes I had two great pleasure of
directing Sandy in the film hope floats
and I got to see firsthand the beauty of
her work what she does with such ease
but some missed the delicacies and the
complexities inside of it but the
breadth and the depth of her heart which
she allows us to share is that
intangible magical quality that she can
never miss Anna Sondra public
performance
every British Prime Minister should end
up in a relationship with a wonderful
Queen I had that privilege in the
oscar-nominated best picture where Helen
Mirren won for Best Actress for her
portrayal of Elizabeth the second now I
spend a lot of time on the set with
Helen and after a while I thought kept
reoccurring is it wrong to be so wildly
attracted to a queen I mean she was
Elizabeth but then after a few hours the
makeup would start to wear off and her
spider web tattoo would start to appear
on her hand which of course only made
her even hotter royalty with a tattoo
brilliant and this past year she somehow
matched that amazing performance with
another one playing the countess Sofia
in the last station she showed us a
woman's guile and heart and pride and
desperation a portrayal that only comes
from an actress with immense talent and
one who is never afraid to take a risk
it is that combination Helen of talent
and courage and yes that tattoo that
makes you our Queen our countess and an
Oscar nominee congratulations
Carey Mulligan Carey Mulligan has fallen
in love with me twice actually not with
me personally but with the characters I
played once on stage opposite her and
then once in the film which she's
nominated tonight I'm afraid I treated
her badly
I'm sorry Carrie I should have told you
that I was married but uh out of her
amazing depth Grace and intelligence
came unforgettable portraits of
heartbreak and complexity her
performance in an education is indeed
just that we are lucky that she is so
young because we have a lifetime of her
work to look forward to being honored is
still strange to you I imagine
but given what she's already shown us
it's something you're going to have to
get used to darling
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Gabourey Sidibe she was a student trying
to earn some money to go to college on
Monday she skipped school to audition
for a movie called
precious on Tuesday they called her back
to meet the director Lee Daniels on
Wednesday she got the part and tonight
she is sitting at the Academy Awards in
the same category as Meryl Streep
[Applause]
[Music]
I tell you that in the Hollywood fairy
tale what is the authenticity Gabi with
which you played the harsh brutal moment
in our movie precious where did that
come from the transformation from your
own your own joyous positive radiant fun
self to the heartbreaking despair of
that girl
precious where did you learn how to do
that when we look at you we see a true
American Cinderella on the threshold of
a brilliant new career and precious is
but the first of many adjectives coming
your way and they are all great
congratulations
Gabby Sidibe
[Music]
maril what can I say that like most
people in the world I have been in love
with you for years that the two movies
we did together were the highlights of
my career that you were brilliant in
both of them as you are in everything
that the mantle of most acclaimed film
actress of our time could not be worn
with more grace and humility but
everyone already knows that but they
don't know is your kindness your
collaborative nature your great good
humor those things make you a dream to
work with and a wonderful friend it is
in the area of awards and accolades
however that you show a certain how can
I say this a certain selfishness that is
unseemly that is why I have spearheaded
a movement in the Academy to cap the
number of nominations per actor at 16
which means that this could be the last
time that anyone will have to stand up
here and say despite their personal
feelings that Meryl Streep is quite
simply the best
ladies and gentlemen a two-time Academy
Award recipient was last year's winner
for Actor in a leading role Sean Penn
[Music]
I never became an official member of the
Academy but the Academy and I do have in
common that we managed to neglect to
acknowledge the same actress in our own
ways and two years running so I am gonna
start fresh with the Academy and and
acknowledged these wonderful actresses
here are the nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a leading
role Sandra Bullock The Blind Side Helen
Mirren molestation
Carey Mulligan in an education
Gabourey Sidibe the precious
on meryl streep for Julie Angelina
[Music]
and the winner is Sandra Bullock
the first Academy Award and nomination
for Sandra Bullock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did I really earn this or did I just
wear y'all down III would like to thank
the Academy for allowing me in the last
month to have the most incredible ride
with rooms full of artists that I see
tonight and that I worked with before
and I hope to work with in the future
who inspire me and blazed trails for us
four of them that I've fallen deeply in
love with I share this night with and I
share this award with Gabby I love you
so much you are exquisite you are beyond
words to me carry your grace and your
elegance and your beauty and your talent
makes me sick
Helen I feel like we are family through
family and I I don't have the words to
express just what I think of you and
Meryl you know what I think of you and
you're such a good kisser I have so many
people to thank for my good fortune in
this lifetime and this is a
once-in-a-lifetime experience I know to
the family that allowed me to play them
the TUI family I know they're in here
and you'll probably hear her in a minute
maybe not thank you for giving me the
opportunity to the family that made this
film that gave me the opportunity to do
something different John Lee Hancock
gillnetter Alcon Warner Brothers the
actors everyone who's shown me kindness
when it wasn't fashionable I thank you
to everyone who was mean to me when it
wasn't felt like George Clooney threw me
in a pool years ago I'm still holding a
grudge but there's so many people to
thank not enough time so I would like to
thank what this film was about for me
which are the moms that take care of the
babies and the children no matter where
they come from
those moms and parents never get thanked
I in particular failed to thank one so
if I can take this moment to thank Helga
be um for not letting me writing cards
with boys till I was 18 cuz she was
right I would have done what she said I
was gonna do for making me practice
every day when I got home piano ballet
whatever it is I wanted to be she said
to be an artist you had to practice
every day and for reminding her
daughters that there's no race no
religion no class system no color
nothing no sexual orientation that makes
us better than anyone else we are all
deserving of love so to that trailblazer
who allowed me to have that in this in
this I thank you so much for this
opportunity that I share with these
extraordinary women and my lover meryl
streep
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]